foreign
[Music]
thus what belongs to the element of
picture thinking that is that absolute
Spirit qua individual or rather qua
particular Spirit presents the nature of
spirit in its natural existence is here
shifted into self-consciousness itself
into knowledge that preserves itself in
its otherness
this self-consciousness therefore does
not actually die as the particular
self-consciousness is pictured as being
actually dead but its particularity dies
away in its universality that is in its
knowledge which is essentially being
reconciling itself with itself
the immediately preceding element of
picture thinking is therefore here
explicitly set aside or it has returned
into the self into its notion what was
in the former merely in the element of
being has become a subject
by this very fact the first element to
Pure thinking and the eternal spirit
therein is no longer beyond the picture
and Consciousness or beyond the self on
the contrary the return unto itself of
the whole is just this to contain within
itself all the moments
the death of the mediator is grasped by
the self is the supercession of his
objective existence or his particular
being for self this particular being for
self has become a universal
self-consciousness
on the other side the universal has
become self-consciousness just because
of this and the Pure or non-actual
Spirit of mere thinking has become
actual
the death of the mediator is the death
not only of his natural aspect or of his
particular being for self not only of
the already dead husk stripped of its
essential being but also of the
abstraction of the Divine being
for the mediator insofar as his death
has not yet completed the reconciliation
is the one-sidedness which takes as
essential being the simple element of
thought in contrast to actuality
this one-sided extreme of the self does
not as yet have equal worth with
essential being this it first has as
spirit
the death of this picture thought
contains therefore at the same time the
death of the abstraction of the Divine
being which is not posited as self
that death is the painful feeling of the
unhappy Consciousness that God himself
is dead this hard saying is the
expression of innermost simple
self-knowledge the return of
Consciousness into the depths of the
night in which I equals I a night which
no longer distinguishes or knows
anything outside of it the feeling is in
fact the loss of substance and of its
appearance over against Consciousness
but it is at the same time the pure
subjectivity of substance or the pure
certainty of itself which it lacked when
it was object or the immediate or pure
Essence this knowing is the inbrething
of the spirit whereby substance becomes
subject by which it's abstraction and
lifelessness have died and substance
therefore has become actual and simple
and Universal self-consciousness
getting close to the end of the religion
section and ready to step Across the
Threshold into the final section of
hegel's phenomenology we have this very
fascinating paragraph
785 which is focused on the death of the
mediator and the implications that we
can draw out of it at this point not
just for all these great metaphysical
things like substance and subject and
self and self-consciousness which are
quite important but also for we could
call it the medium and it is indeed a
medium that we use of representation or
picture thinking or imagination of force
telling and what we see here is not just
a Reconciliation that is taking place
for Spirit it in the death of the
mediator which turns out not to be
complete death let's say but a
recuperation
of picture thinking
it's not being thrown completely away
and if we jump ahead just a little bit
right we have this very interesting
passage by this very fact the first
element to Pure thinking and the eternal
spirit therein which is what we want
right that's the good stuff
is no longer
beyond the picturing Consciousness the
Consciousness that works through the
medium of representation that you could
say confines itself to that that doesn't
suspect that there is an entire range of
better Thinking Beyond the merely
pictured or represented right so it's no
longer beyond the picturing
Consciousness or beyond the self and now
notice this incredibly important line
here on the contrary the return into
itself
of the whole is just this to contain
within itself all of the moments this is
you could say one of the undergirding
concepts running throughout all of
hegel's philosophy and in particular the
phenomenology where we're making all
these gestures and efforts and work
trying you know it's not quite a linear
process either it's more of a zigzag
process you could say to try to attain
this
understanding I was almost tempted to
say picture of but that would be
representation again wouldn't it an
understanding a comprehension of the
whole of the totality the gods right the
everything
that
um
alone allows everything to be placed
into its proper not just place but
perspective and function you could say
so that's a lot of preface there let's
jump now into looking at it from the
very beginning so he says what belongs
to the element of picture thinking
namely that absolute Spirit qua
individual or rather qua particular
Spirit right so we've got absolute
spirits and then it is being
presented put forward
postulated however you want to say it as
a particular individual who is the
particular individual well this guy
who's going to die the Incarnate God the
god that has become not just in fleshed
but has become human right
so he says it presents the nature of
spirit in its existence so what belongs
to the element of picture thinking
presents the nature of spirit in its
natural existence is here
shifted into self-consciousness itself
into knowledge that preserves itself in
its otherness so self-consciousness as
we've seen many many times in this
section also back in the
self-consciousness section also in the
spirit section in particular
self-consciousness is only
self-consciousness in relation to an
other or rather an entire world of
others right self-consciousness is not a
stable being in and of itself it is for
itself and for others as well and we've
seen that this is taking place in the
community right so he says
um the self-consciousness therefore does
not actually die
as the particular self-consciousness is
pictured represented as being actually
dead so now we've got sort of an
allegorizing here right so but
interestingly the usually when we talk
about allegory we mean a story that's
actually telling another story and those
could both be on the level of four
Stallone right but this is telling us
about something both metaphysical and
moral at the same time about the nature
of humanity and its history and so what
what do we actually have going on here
he says that the self-conscious is not
actually die as a particular
self-consciousness is represented as
being actually dead but its
particularity dies away in its
universality so
in a certain sense I mean you might be a
little bit worried about that you might
be like well I don't want to lose my
particularity in universality right I
want to I want to remain me right and
the good news is well you don't have to
because
this guy Jesus already did that right
he as God took on this particularity of
human flesh and was killed in in fact
you could say destroyed wiped off the
earth I mean of course there's a body
left behind but in the the resurrection
story no body to be found right and
um because
that person was willing to be completely
absorbed for a gallon hegallian ideas
into this universality or become this
universality we get to do that in ways
that preserve some of the moments of our
individuality our particularity so the
particularity dies away in its
universality and what is that
universality
in its knowledge which is essential
being
reconciling itself with itself so one of
the things that we can realize is that
this Jesus Christ figure
comes back as God comes back to God
comes back within God as the universal
in a different way right and that opens
up a possibility for all of us to find
our own more limited places within this
economy of the universal you could say
so he goes on
and he tells us the immediately
preceding element of picture thinking
therefore here explicitly set aside
or it is returned into the self into its
notion right so it picture thinking
hasn't been like thrown away gotten rid
of entirely it's going to be brought in
to a better perspective and you know
he's going to talk about this Miller's
going to translate it as supersession
auf haben in just a bit well this is one
of those key hegelian Concepts Alf
haibonger Alf haben Haven is of course
the verb right habong is a sort of
substantive of that verb to supersede to
transcend to
incorporate while throwing away the
inessential elements to bring into a
larger Matrix of meaning well that is
what is going
on here a supersession of what
of picture and notice I put this into in
a little you know cutesy way that's so
common with Continental thought in the
late 20th century it's not just picture
thinking it's pictured thinking and
that's part of the problem with for
Stellar right it is pictured it is
produced it is turned into something
that we can all like look at me oh the
objectivity right there right something
that presents itself to us we like that
but it doesn't adequately communicate
the notion the concept that because if
the living thought
that it is that we're after at this
point in time living thought not just in
an abstract way but living thought as
oriented around what is most important
in not just our own individual lives but
in the history of human consciousness
now we could quibble and say ah Hegel
you know product of a eurocentric
Christian culture that thought that uh
you know the Christian story is the most
important and maybe there's some truth
to that but we don't have to worry about
that at this point more important is
figuring out what what is Hegel actually
saying here and then we can think about
implications for world religions at some
other time or a broader uh you know
conceptual approach to this sort of
thing in the 21st century it's enough
just to figure out what hegel's doing
here in the early 1800s and so anyway he
he says
um this immediately preceding element of
picture thinking uh is returned into
itself into its notion and what does
this mean what was in the former merely
in the element of being has become a
subject
this is not an idea that we haven't
encountered before right uh South uh
substance Spirit subject all these four
s's I mean this has been an important
theme really since the preface and then
took on a really important role in the
spirit section and in the religion
section but we want to think about this
for a moment what does it mean to be a
subject
it means having agency
it means
having a certain capacity not just to
act on other things but upon oneself to
get to know oneself to
decide about oneself to be a subject
this is a bit of a digression here to be
a subject unless we're talking about the
absolute subject at the absolute end of
History
is inherently paradoxical perhaps even
in a hegelian sense contradictory right
there are going to be
contradictions which you know might be
just at the level of you know things
that are set in opposition and gagan
gestanded right
um you know which we sometimes translate
as antithesis or opposed right it might
be an actual contradiction a gig and
zots right where there's there's a
genuine contradiction there and what's
what's really interesting about the
hegelian approach is when we hit a
contradiction we're not like oh well
contradiction therefore we're finished
no no some contradictions can be worked
through
and the contradiction of being a subject
the contradiction involved in being a
subject
is continually worked through at least
in implicit ways
and here it's being worked through in an
explicit way one that involves mediation
and death
so he goes on and he says
um by this very fact the first element
two pure thinking in the eternal spirit
therein is no longer beyond the picture
in Consciousness on the contrary the
return into itself of the whole is just
this to contain within itself all the
moments this this passage we started
with what are all the moments a lot of
them are in fact picture thinking right
so we're not Throwing It All Away we're
figuring out how they connect with each
other what they actually mean and here
he's going to talk about the mediator
the mittler right and this is you know
quite important mediation is absolutely
Central and hegelian dialectics
realizing what's mediating what in this
case we have a mediator who is mediating
for himself or itself two different
sides uh the God man right
but is also offering us the possibility
of mediation as well
so he says the death of the mediator is
grasped by the self
is the supercession right there we've
got the ALF Haven of his objective
existence right and that's gig and
Stanley kite there's no dozen in there
so Miller's translation a little bit a
little bit uh misleading perhaps
the being an object that we can
encounter right so I mean think about
how the disciples encountered Christ
there were some suspicions that he
indeed was God but it's mostly like wow
this guy gave us some fish and some wine
and some teachings and wow this is this
is a great person to be around right so
the death of the mediator is the super
session of his objective existence or
his particular being for self
right
it's a person there not just an object
and it's particular and he goes on he
says this particular being for self has
become a universal
self-consciousness Christ becomes the
Christian Community but is also God
right
on the one side on the other side he
says the universal has become is Vernon
is the word that he's using there has
become self-consciousness
right algae minus zeb's design is what
we're dealing with here just because of
this and the Pure or non-actual Spirit
of mere thinking
has become actual another very important
hegelian idea right thinking awesome
great wonderful we want to be thinking
right but mere Thinking by itself that
doesn't become actual doesn't become
vehicle real in the world translated
into action or comportment it's just
mere thinking right so this is the
universal
particularizing itself in a way right by
becoming actual so he says the death is
the me of the mediator is the death
not only of his natural aspect or of his
particular being for self
not only of the already dead husked
stripped of its essential being you know
the Corpus the body if you think about a
crucifix it's kind of funny if you think
about it
um Christians have long since had
depictions of the Dead Christ and it
comes in a couple different forms right
you've got them hanging there on the
cross and you know there's kind of an
ambiguity is is it supposed to be
representing picturing a still living
tortured and dying man God or does it
depict the dead man God who has expired
along with the two thieves on the cross
at Calvary
we could also say similar things about
artistic representations like the pieta
showing you know Mary cradling her dead
son right now his mission over
um there's definitely a depiction of the
Dead thing the husk there right that's
perhaps what Hagel is referring to the
already dead husk stripped of his
essential being it's not just the
individual who is dying but Hegel goes
on
also the abstraction
of the Divine being
right
he says for the mediator insofar as his
death has not yet completed the
reconciliation
is the one-sidedness which takes as
essential being the simple element of
thought in contrast to actuality
so
neither side really ought to have
priority there is a tendency as Hegel is
going to point out to Accord to Great
await to the side of the universal as
opposed to the individual and he goes on
and he says
um
this one-sided extreme of the self does
not yet have equal worth with essential
being
this at first has as Spirit what is this
the uh equal worth
right it attains it so he goes on and he
says the death of this picture thought
contains therefore at the same time the
death of the abstraction of the Divine
being which is not posited as self so
two sides are being revealed as
inadequate as not the full story here
the side of objective existence the
particular being for self the side of
the abstraction of divine being not
positive as self it's got to be
transformed into Universal
self-consciousness within the community
Through the mediator
and how is this going to happen
well he tells us
and here is making a reference back to
an earlier part of the phenomenology at
the very end of the self-consciousness
section actually I shouldn't say at the
very end because it's the longest part
of the self-consciousness section the
unhappy Consciousness right uh the the
Spirit as human beings extending their
ideas out into a Beyond which they try
to map onto to meet up with through all
sorts of efforts and continually fail in
the process in that he actually so this
is one of the key phrases that comes up
uh he says the death of the picture
thought contains at the same time the
death of the abstraction the Divine
being not positive as self the self
that's seeking it that death is the
painful feeling of the unhappy
Consciousness what feeling not just a
thought but a Feeling
that God himself
is dead gesturban ist
and it's kind of funny here in a little
bit of word play
um it's not just that God is dead God is
toot right God is gesturban right God
has died God is a dead thing a thing
that has died
is if we want to unpack the language a
little bit here and play around with it
getting away from the idiomatic use and
looking at the pure lexicality of it now
Hegel goes on and he says this hard
saying is the expression of innermost
simple
self-knowledge the return of
Consciousness into the depths of the
night in which I equals I a night which
no longer distinguishes or knows
anything outside of it well that doesn't
sound good that sounds like we you know
had this Big Arc oh we're getting closer
and closer to the reconciliation of
everything and great Alf Hamburg and
everything being connected in a hole and
boom we go down into a lack of
Distinction the you know proverbial
night in which all cows are black a pure
identity statement of I equals I
something we can't do anything with
right so that is the death that we're
staring in the face not just this guy
hanging on the cross who sacrificed
himself in this long narrative about God
and propitiation and atonement and etc
etc right this is something metaphysical
and he says that there's a feeling here
the feeling is in fact the loss of
substance
and its appearance
over against Consciousness now the word
here that's being translated as
appearance gagan Uber threatens coming
out to so appearing works but it's
rather something that is actually
um
exercising some some opposition to the
uh Consciousness right Gigan uh but
Voice sign is the over against
Consciousness so the loss of substance
over against Consciousness we lose our
our grasp on the threat of of substance
but then he says or the pure certainty
of itself which it lacked when it was
object or the immediate
or pure Essence so all of those are
rolled into this loss of substance which
now becomes something different and then
he brings up something really
interesting this knowing is the here's
the translation right the in-breathing
of
spirits
right uh which is the geistong becoming
spirit
The Knowing is the inbrething of the
spirit whereby and here we get these you
know massively important terms and we
get a metaphysical interpretation
substance becomes subject and
self-consciousness what Hegel actually
says
whereby in this spiritualization
substance becomes subject by which it's
abstraction and lifelessness have died
so subject is living subject right
substance becomes something living
something a gentle something that can do
things something that has desires
something that has movement and he goes
on and uh but oh yeah by which it's
abstraction and lifelessness of diet
substance therefore
has become notice these three qualifying
terms
actual and simple and Universal
self-consciousness now where are we
going to find that well Universal
self-consciousness we know is the
religious community right
that's been called that now for
paragraph after paragraph actual vehicle
league in the world existing
incorporating objective existences
particular individual uh beings for
ourself right uniting them into the
community and simple and [ __ ] right
that's also important Simplicity uh out
of
plurality we could say by focusing by
engaging in this super session so we
have ton of stuff going on here
including hegel's we we might say
practically definitive
interpretation of what the death of the
mediator Christ
should actually mean for us